CHARGES.
>>A REIDM
DUPREE, THANK YOR WEEK ASSAULTE
CLAIHE THEN TER 22 OUTAL
FIGHTING.
THE LEADERIS. SAY UKRNIS
STILL IN CONTROL ODINGS
UKRAINE FOR US.OBERTSON IS I
IS THIS POTENTIAL DEFEAT
LE THE
RUN?eporter: YES I
IT MORALE ISSUE.
IT'S A MORALE FO AND
FOE RUSSIANS, THE RUSSIANS
GA
THIS IS A TOUGH R E UKRAINIANS.
'VE LOSTHI MANY SOLDIERS QUESTI
THEILITICAL LEADERDIGHDECISION,?
THE COUNTERNARRATIVE IS INTOD K
SS
IF RUSSIA PUSHES THROUGH BAKHMUS
E FRONLINES
VERY, VERY CLOSE TO U SEM SOIEI
ING ARTILLERY.M A KICKINRED TROO
WEG TO WAIIN TS ASEMENT UNS .
A LAR SAFE TO COMEILL BE SAFE
CALLE GAMBIT TS IER IS STILL SH
WE'LL GET BACK IN THE VEHICLE
AN A LERRONT LINES.
TEN DAYS A THESES PUSHEDTH BAC
BAKHMUT, BUT T ISLOWING .
SHON FRONTINE,OMING
FROMAN HARHES IN BAKHMUT
YOU CAN  EXPERIENC.AN E IT.EY S.
THEY ALLK
TH MORALE ISIGH, BUT
THEIR FACES ARE TEA
ENORY.
WE MOVE  OONS AND OPS THE SHELL.
WE'LPUD GO SOMEWHERESE.ON BUN T
COMMANDER LLS  THES
TROOPS SCEADVANCED.LINON
TONS O
BAS NEARMUT.THANYEGHANMORALE. S
HMSTPS ARE EXHAUSTEDBU
S THDE ON IN HOWSSIA'S WEALT NIN
WEAPONRY SPO ITSALLIESO STRUGGLE
TO TIP THEFOX D HIS UN LD
UP FOR THEIR HAR THEFRONN END O
BACK TO THEIR FAMILIES, WHAT
DRIVES THEM INING.
>>LORATIST RCES WHO ARED
NE HAVE CROSSED THE  ACTUALLDE
>>EAH.LOOK, WHAT THEIRE
DOING IN AND AUNMUT AND
OTHEAC ALONG THE FRONT  AKNESS S
LINES,RCE THRUSSIANS T
AREA TO ANOTHER.
I THINK WHAT WITNESSING AT
THE BORDER, HOW BIZARRE, THAT
ESSEIAN ALLIED FORC AOSE
BORDER INTO RUSSS  WH INTHEY CAL
ER CAN T
BOER TAKE SO WEAK, AANUKRAINIANE
PRISON P
HE BACK FOOT UNDER ASSAUDOING ET
APPEARS AS IF THEAINIANS
ARE TRYING TE THIANS
TOOOPST IN UKRAINE TO GE
E BORDD THESE
MANY, MANY HUNDRED BORDE
ARENTLY
THEY'RE NOT DEFEND